she never star company with the goal of
getting rich it's not about the money
don't do it for money
what's that believe nation it's Evan my
one word is believe and I believe in you
I believe you have Michael Jordan level
talent at something and I want you to
find it embrace it and use it to make a
difference now I started the one rule
series because I do a lot of top tens
and we see a lot of content and some of
the rules repeat themselves over and
over and over again so that's the goal
with this series where the most common
rules we smush them gather into one
video for you so today we're gonna look
at how you can stop focusing on the
money also if you want to know what Gary
Vaynerchuk Bill Gates and other
entrepreneurs have to say a bill
building unstoppable confidence check
out my 250 for confidence where every
day for the next 254 days I will send
you a short 30 second to 5 minute videos
to help you build confidence for free
check out the link in the description
below and so you really have to believe
the Internet's going to be mainstream a
lot of people are gonna get out there
and use it and that they're going to be
willing to pay for some content is that
the operating idea that you have well
each of these businesses is an
entrepreneurial business the
overreaching theme is that yes I believe
in the internet I believe it'll get
increasingly popular and we're doing
some neat new things to take advantage
of that on a bigger macro
patience and failure they all ladder up
to one thing which is insecurity the
reason people don't put themselves in a
position to fail the reason people
aren't patient is they value other
people's opinions too much focus is
controlled by questions if you ask a
different question continuously not once
continuously you will get a different
answer if you ask a lousy question he
get allows the answer and a lousy State
somebody said why does this always
happen to me it doesn't always happen to
you but the brains like a computer I ask
it a question you don't have to come up
with an answer Steve Jobs said that you
should never start a company with the
goal of getting rich it should be about
starting a company to make something you
believe it we shouldn't in you to make a
difference break down boundaries
borders and ignite ideas to innovate
incessantly and create for people where
they can never conjure up themselves
Henry Ford said that if I had asked
people what they wanted they would have
said faster horses and that's the beauty
of being beyond wanting money and going
beyond wanting fame then the unwanted
power that you actually craft something
that involves people's daily lives that
you actually create something that
enhances someone's human experience
people respond to people who want to do
more than just gain for themselves we
were attracted by selflessness we're
attracted by renunciation we're
attracted by the quality of when people
want to give rather than take well they
want to share rather than keeping when
they wanna do and serve rather than just
hold Steve Jobs said being the richest
man in the cemetery doesn't matter to me
what matters to me is going to sleep
feeling like we've done really wonderful
I absolutely know I will be the greatest
entrepreneur of this era because I'm
gonna win on the two fronts that people
gonna judge by I'll make enough money so
that I'm in the conversation and I will
inspire and help more entrepreneurs than
the rest of the field combined I'm
talking to all of them because what Elon
Musk does in his actions to inspire is
incredible it's incredible and Steve
Jobs and then but what I'm doing is
different and I know it the end cuz and
by the way it's cuz I want it more
something I'm better I just want that
that's the part I want I'm it's what
this whole thing is that's why the
document like people don't understand
what I'm actually doing that I'm leaving
so much like from a businessman see but
I'm leaving so much money on the table
but money's not to go no you know what's
funny for me money stop being a goal at
$100,000 I couldn't believe I made a
hundred thousand dollars a year I was
like that was it and since then
nothing's been the same doesn't feel the
same not a million not a million doesn't
feel the same a hundred thousand so you
are here with your daughter who is 21
right and you were 21 when
you became a billionaire is that right
almost yeah all right so I round that
age you wouldn't you were like the
youngest person to become a billionaire
is that right yeah yeah in terms of my
own earning it on my own yeah right okay
so what's just the most important thing
yeah so did you when you were a kid did
you did you care about money or you just
cared about technology and that's it
just happened
mostly I'd love software I do remember
at the private school I went to there
were other kids whose families were
better off like they had a porch or
something but it wasn't that that big of
a deal my thing was that I just love
doing software I loved hiring people and
I was stunned when it ended up being so
valuable really yeah you it surprised
you yeah because I always had to be
careful that we wouldn't hire too many
people I was always worried because I've
people who work for me or older than me
and they had kids and I always thought
well what if we don't get paid will I be
able to meet the payroll so I was always
very conservative about the finances and
then when we did go public
what was I thirty by then then I was
kind of stunned at what it multiplied
out to I had I had this idea that I was
going to you know buy and sell crash
cars right so I'll buy it at five
thousand put twenty five hundred into it
and then sell it at ten thousand it's
simple and if you put the math together
I was gonna do that every month and then
they would start compounding in two
three years I was gonna be a decision
heir yeah pretty much simple I had it
all planned out of that coke and I love
I love joking saying mike tyson's you
know theory is uh you know everybody has
a plan until they get punched in the
face and life will punch you in the face
I pretty much got punched in the face
price six months into it and then I
found myself working a Red Lobster with
none of that money because I was trying
to do it for money yeah you know um I
hate I really hate working on cars
because I can't work on them my hands
are really buttery soil my hands feel
like veal
I'm not supposed to work on a car man
and I'm thinking you know you know that
about yourself though I love that you
well I do it myself after the first
transmission you know crush my footing
and I really like you know what I think
I think hats are better you know so but
again you know a lot of people out there
chasing their dream but their dream is
to just be rich and that's not a dream
you know if you if you if you if you try
to go out and make just make money for
the purpose of making money first of all
you could end up in the wrong place due
to it you could be miserable and then
when you get it if you don't have no
goal on why you were trying to achieve
this goal you feel unfulfilled also my
goal in the book is really for people to
be happy and more fulfilled because you
got a ton of money and still being
miserable right you know so it's it's
really it's it's like mastering the
science of achievement but also the art
of fulfillment it's about if you're
totally successful you're not fulfilled
then what do you get nothing
yeah you made everybody happy but
yourself you know that's the worst thing
you've got that that's Robin Williams is
a beautiful man such a beautiful man
killed himself right and he achieved
everything most people have a dream I've
had a beautiful family you've made the
whole world laugh hundreds of million
people walk in but you didn't figure out
how to end the suffering money won't do
that I saw a report that you turned down
a hundred million dollar offer from a
Chinese club to come here and play in
Los Angeles we don't mean to get all in
your business but for what we here three
years two years rather three million
dollars for fairly gasps what why that's
97 million dollars left on the table I
mean yeah I mean this is this is a big
challenge for me I want to come over
here to the US play for galaxy and show
show everybody what what I'm able to do
and it's not about the money because I
didn't even know my contract I had here
so I just had prepared and I'm coming
and and I think even galaxy was
surprised so like I said after my injury
I just want to be happy I push it every
time I put on the football shoes and
just melt the grass touch the ball and
and do what I've been doing for the last
20 years and and trust me that has no
price so here is the reality about money
so the reason that people
you said even though I know you've heard
a thousand times and it is absolutely
true money can't buy happiness that if
you're chasing money the odds of you
ending up with some level of
dissatisfaction is incredibly high but
the reason that people ignore that and
the reason that they keep chasing it the
reason that I myself live the cliche of
money can't buy happiness is because
money actually does have power now the
thing that money lets you do the thing
that gives it that power the reason that
people will chase for ever and ever and
ever is it is the great facilitator now
being the great facilitator does not
mean that it gives you the thing that
you secretly want in your life so here's
the punchline about happiness the goal
of all of this the goal of this game of
life that we're all playing it is not
money
it is not success it is entirely brain
chemistry it's entirely how you feel
about yourself when you're by yourself
it's about being deeply fulfilled it's
about being proud of who you are now
those are all for me synonyms it's the
same thing which I'm just going to
shorthand to fulfillment the thing
you're chasing is fulfillment it's the
only thing that doesn't sway with the
wind so happiness in its typical
definition is very transient so I want
to shift people over to thinking about
fulfillment fulfillment is often born of
suffering it's born of not doing
something you want to do it's born of
doing the hard things being proud of
yourself comes from that being proud of
yourself comes from working your ass off
to acquire a set of skills that by the
way in and of themselves in acquiring it
you found that pleasurable it's
something that you're interested in
you've hopefully crafted developed built
a deep passion around and in acquiring
those skills in service of that thing
that you love and enjoy you're able to
serve other people that's it that's the
truth
of happiness that's the truth of the
thing that is going to give you that
sense of fulfillment that's going to
allow you to enjoy your life money is
never ever ever in and of itself going
to do that money buys cool money is able
to give you those temporary dopamine
rushes of going and shopping for
something
then it's cool but then that coolness
factor wears off very rapidly the
flipside of that using that money to
build something that you believe in that
not only empowers you but helps empower
other people that will help you develop
long lasting fulfillment so that's the
real thing but if you're doing something
that isn't making you a lot of money but
you're passionate about it you enjoy the
day-to-day and it's allowing you to
build skills that serve you and other
people I promise you if you had to
choose between the two which by the way
you don't but if you had to choose
between the two always in forever every
single time choose fulfillment I think
the plan between me and my dad was he
had a bit of money saved I would go in
like to London learn skills give it four
or five years then I will come up I put
my savings and his savings together we'd
get a bank loan and we'd get a little
pub in the country maybe 65 covers and
kind of do my version of what Dad did
and that was that was honestly that was
the total plan signed sealed delivered
mm-hmm that was that was it and I was
really excited for it and you know and I
and and the concept of money I mean when
you become a chef you do not become a
chef to be rich you don't know I know
there's no money until you're a head
chef ray and even then how even have
failed I mean honestly it is there's no
one in technology that makes less money
I mean let me even head chefs compared
to technologists nothing so it's you
don't do it for money so you do it
because you love it or because you're
lost so I was just very very happy with
the dream of a pub in the country
probably back home near dad but not too
close so I take his estimates you know
yeah he was pretty clear about that
I've never craved money I've never been
proud of money per se in fact for the
first few years of getting a newfound
wealth I felt guilty about it and I
still feel a little bit over Yelland
because there was a nobility in in
poverty really and and so I've always
thought that if I'm gonna be rich and
famous then I've got to be proud
of how I made my money and how I got my
fame and making money making money I've
never understood it you know I never
understood it I don't play those games I
don't play that I don't try and make
more money I never I've never tried to
make money
come on come on you know be an actor
because you love to act I'm being active
cuz you think you're gonna get famous
cuz that's luck but if it's what you
want to do with your whole heart so come
on go everywhere learn everything like
Shakespeare Shakespeare is great fun
don't be thrown by the words the words
are the same words that we use you know
with a little different implementation
you know write things for yourself come
on it's a great way to spend time it's a
great way to learn history you know it's
great way to learn all kinds of things
but only come if you come into play if
you're not coming to play you should get
another gig to supplement your acting
now I've got a really special bonus clip
with sadguru around being interested in
people that I think you're really gonna
enjoy but before that let's bring it
home with the three-point landing
questions I want to make sure you're
moving from not just watch another video
but to actually taking action in your
business so listen to these three
questions write down the answers in a
notebook yourself talk about them with a
friend or leave them in the comments
below here we go question number one
what is your why
question number two what is the best way
that you can help people in question
number three how can you then make money
from that work thank you guys so much
for watching I believe in you I hope you
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is much love I'll
see you soon and enjoy the bonus clip
this just a couple of weeks ago I was in
conversation with someone who is
considered some kind of an expert on
Internet affairs and social media and
all this so he's been looking at our
material in the YouTube and various
other platforms and I said ve I can give
you 50 times more than what is there
you know just people work on all the
thousands of hours of audio and video
that's there in the archive 50 times
more in a year's time we can multiply it
by 50 that much material is there he
said so guru already what is there here
you're throwing it all over the place is
worth a billion dollars I said see what
will I do with the billion dollars my
interest is seven billion people I have
no interest in billion dollars what do I
do with it
my interest is people altruistic world
domination
honey Empire right I'm grateful I
understand why I'm here I think because
I am so open I wanted to think I see
it's a bloody brief life all of you have
the potential for enormous success if
you want to know what gary vee DJ khalid
oprah and others know about empire
building that most people miss check out
the link in the description for a free
bonus video